[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir tout le monde j'espère que vous
allez bien alors je me présente je
m'appelle fiche tombe aussi et je
l'étais clairement pas destiné à réussir
j'étais même condamné à l'échec je vous
raconte je suis noir j'ai grandi à evry
courcouronnes dans un quartier difficile
et j'habite à 30 km de paris à l'école
j'ai toujours été dans l'intérêt de la
classe dernier avant dernier ou avant
avant dernier et même pour ceux tedx
j'ai failli passer en dernier
les aurait été gratifiants j'aurais aimé
passer en dernier dans ce tedx
ça c'est une photo de mon bulletin
scolaire de la saison 2002 2003 je vous
laisse regarder les notes et les
appréciations
j'excellais que dans une seule matière
le
psg était bon quand le ps mais
la plupart de mes appréciations
entre moscow la ridt et c'était à la
tête dans les nuages passe son temps à
rêver avertissements travailler conduite
toute la scolarité comme aux enfants
pour voir cette vidéo c'est là qu'ils
vont voir que je leur manque depuis les
débuts
ma fille à 11 ans monfils a 9 ans et à
chaque fois je leur dis tu fais un bon
métier il faut bien travailler à l'école
tu vois pas il a un bon métier c'est
parce qu'il a bien travaillé à l'école
quand on voir cette vidéo cela qu'ils
vont voir que c'est foutu pour moi c'est
foutu pour moi
je n'ai aucun diplôme enfin si j'en ai
donné deux diplômes j'ai un bep
comptabilité et un bep hôtellerie mais
pour moi c'est comme si j'avais pas
diplômes parce que en france les
diplômes sont valorisés et avec mes deux
diplômes ont brassé pas top j'ai même
pas le brevet des collèges d'ailleurs la
veille de passer mon brevet il y avait
un concert de rap organisé dans ma ville
du groupe ideal j
c'était un concert de four concert de
malades non j'en garde des souvenirs de
fou le concert a fini vers 23h30 minuit
je rentrais chez moi le lendemain il y
avait les preuves du brevet forcément
j'avais encore la tête dans le concert
donc du coup bas j'ai foiré ont les
preuves concernant mon profil tous les
éléments étaient réunis pour que je
fasse un travail alimentaire ou que je
fasse un métier qui ne correspondent pas
avec un tel cv aucun patron n'aurait
voulu prendre un jeune comme moi c'est
comme ça sur mon front et avait écrit
défavorablement connu des services de
police ouais compliqué et du coup mais
pour moi je me plains pas il n'est pas
question de faire du misérabilisme
depuis le départ j'ai été briefé sur ma
condition
d'être un jeune de quartier et d'être
noir en france ma mère m'a toujours dit
ne fait pas remarquer travaille bien à
l'école ramène des bonnes notes
faites-vous petit les frères et moi on a
fait tout le contraire
ma mère à la galerie franchement là l'a
fait un peu souffrir mais
c'était c'était dur mais c'était une
battante elle nous dit tout le temps
faites-vous petit vous êtes déjà noir
vous fait déjà remarquer restez à votre
place
dire que vous êtes noir il faudra faire
deux fois trois fois plus que les autres
pour avoir plus que les autres vous
n'êtes pas comme les autres et à chaque
fois 10 et les autres les autres mais
c'est qui les autres je pense qu'elle
parlait d élève de l'essec un an je
pense que quand je disais les autres
parler de vous ah ouais non ma mère
c'est une vaillante ma mersen vaillante
et moi j'ai perdu mon père à l'âge de 8
ans et ma mère est là bien jouer les
deux rôles elle a joué de rôle mes
frères et moi honnêtement on n'a manqué
de rien j'avais deux choses pour moi
heureusement c'était la bonne éducation
parce que ma mère nous a très bien
éduqué mes frères et moi j'ai grandi
sans père mon père à l'âge de 8 ans est
vraiment n'avons manqué de là la
deuxième chose que j'avais pour moi
c'était le rap à le rap musique rap rap
musique que j'aime j'aime ton parfum
comme rap et auxi en 1999 ça c'est moi
dans ma chambre en 1999 j'ai 16 ans je
suis ce qu'on appelle un bousier de rap
à l'europe le rap c'est ma vie ça veut
dire que le rap c'est ma passion
j'écoute du rap toute la journée je
regarde le rap je lis le rap c'est je
suis pas un rappeur jeu précis jamais
rappelé mais le rap moi je vous fais le
rap ma mère a mené tout le temps si tu
connais c'était le son autant que des
chansons de rap tu serais premier de la
classe nd répéter ça tout le temps
ah ouais effectivement elle me répéter
ça et d'ailleurs c'est une phrase que
sur souvent à mes enfants actuellement
et avec mes mauvais bulletin est ma
passion pour le rap ça allait être
compliqué pour moi de réussir dans la
vie parce que on va pas se mentir le rap
avait une mauvaise presse c'était
compliqué d'aimer le rap du coup en 2002
avec un copain mon quartier je lance un
site de rap pour mettre en avant les
rappeurs de mon quartier laventure dure
deux ans en 2004 avec deux autres
copains je lance un site pour mettre en
avant les rappeurs de france ce site
s'appelle booska p.com booska p.com est
un site dédié aux vidéos rap donc bien
avant le lancement de youtube et
dailymotion belle c'est une belle
réussite pour trois jeunes issus d'en
bas issus des quartiers et aujourd'hui
booska-p c'est une trentaine de
personnes qui travaillent booska-p aussi
le plus gros site de rap en france et en
europe
bizarre à tous celles et ceux qui ont
contribué au succès qui continuent
encore à contribuer à cette suite à ce
succès là je pense que nous tous je
pense qu'on est sur terre pour une
mission il y en a qui le savaient qu'ils
le savent pas moi je pense que ma
mission sur terre c'est de mettre en
avant des gens j'ai pas essayé de
redonner parce que étant quelqu'un qui
vient d'en bas qui a grandi en bas j'ai
toujours ce besoin de mettre des gens en
valeur ou de redonner du coup en 2016
julie d2 à force de discussions de me
lancer dans une aventure sur les femmes
dans le rap parce qu'à force des
discussions avec mes collègues que ce
soit des managers des productrices des
réalisatrices je sens j'ai comme un
sentiment que se sentent un peu qu'elles
sont pas valorisées qu'elles se sont un
peu un visibiliser du coup j'ai cette
idée là je fais une série de
documentaires qui est disponible sur
youtube que vous pouvez aller voir et
surtout je pense qu'à ce moment là en
2016 ma fille à cinq ans et je me dis
qu'il faut que je trouve des modèles de
réussite j'ai envie que l est des
modèles actifs identifiés donc du coup
je fais cette série là je pense que et
en ayant été élevé par une femme seule
dans un quartier difficile pour moi dans
mon esprit femme égale femme forte
je continuerai de parler de ce sujet
jusqu'à ce que ça ne devient de plus un
sujet c'est très important pour moi et
qu'on vient des endroits reculés comme
les nôtres ou qu'on vient du quartier ou
convient même des endroits des zones
rurales notre seul espoir un seul but
c'est de rêver on passe notre temps à
rêver on fait partie de cette catégorie
de personnes qui disent quand j'aurai de
l'argent se faire si je faire ça je vais
m'acheter ceci sera donc notre seul
grand luxe et de rêver ouais on rêve
beaucoup parce que rêver ça nous sert à
avoir de la détermination une passion et
de l'envié et surtout d'avoir beaucoup
de déclic et de et de courage
ça fait exactement 20 ans que je fais ce
que je fais et j'ai toujours la même
passion la même dalle la même envie que
quand j'ai commencé en bas de mon
quartier quartier d'ailleurs dont je
suis toujours proche et quand je discute
avec les jeunes quand je me balade dans
plein de quartier de france quand je
ferme mon taf des journalistes je sais
pas j'ai envie de redonner à tous ces
jeunes parce que ils m'ont donné
tellement de force juste envie de
redonner au quartier parce que c'est un
peu le quartier les gens d'en bas qui
m'ont fait qui ont fait que ce que je
suis un peu aujourd'hui parce que ils
m'ont rappelé booster je suis très
impliqué dans la vie de quartier mais
surtout dans un club de foot mon frère
coach des enfants de 8 à 10 ans
ces jeunes lie son smart ils sont très
smart et ils ont
sont remplis de rêves est aussi c'est
moi derrière en blanc confrères il à
genoux avec le ballon est en train de
leur parler de l'intrigué des valeurs là
on est à la mi temps d'un match et
l'entrain de l'ordre et des consignes et
je vais beaucoup à leur entraînement et
à leur match du week-end et franchement
c'est c'est très intéressant parce que
ils ont l'envi mais malheureusement ils
n'ont pas les clés ça c'est des jeunes
j'étais comme à l'époque dernièrement
j'ai la fédération française de football
qui m'a contacté parce qu'ils veulent
organiser un gros shooting il cherche 30
jeunes pour faire partie de la campagne
promo du foot amateur ça va être un gros
shooting organise à clairefontaine
clairefontaine qui est le lieu où se
réalise les joueurs de l'équipe de
france avant les matches internationaux
donc là il petit vont passer toute une
journée du matin 9 heures jusqu'à 17
heures à se faire prendre en photos ils
vont manger là bas ils vont jouer ils
vont se retrouver dans les mêmes
endroits où ou karim benzema qui a name
bape et où le faire un an deiz passent
leur temps avant de de jouer en équipe
de france non ça c'est une grande fierté
j'aurais aimé être à leur place mais je
serai là en tant qu'observateur et et je
vais qui fait je vais qui fait comme
très important de rêver de et de
redonner par rapport à mon implication
et à tous mes engagements tout ce que
j'ai pu faire durant ces vingt ans j'ai
été nommé dernièrement j'ai reçu une
nomination et pas n'importe laquelle
j'étais en bas nommé ambassadeur de la
plus grande compétition mondiale qui va
se dérouler à paris prochainement
j'ai été nommé ambassadeur des jeux
olympiques de paris du programme
jeunesse ça c'est moi avec tony
estanguet le président des jeux
olympiques et paralympiques de parler de
par rapport à tout ce que j'ai pu faire
ils m'ont contacté on dit voilà on
aimerais te nommer ambassadeur du
programme jeunesse culture service
civique génération de 1024 mo celle
intitulée long l'intitulé très long
parce que aura beaucoup de boulot à
faire mais c'est pas seulement c'est
intéressant parce qu'ils veulent faire
de ces jeux olympiques des jeux
olympiques yousif monde va pouvoir y
participer et ce qu'ils veulent vraiment
c'est viser la jeunesse pour moi le
sport c'est un très bon outil le sport
est un très bon outil qui permet de
transmettre des valeurs voilà ça c'est
moi l'intérieur du cojo je tape la pose
et la culture aussi c'est très important
parce que une fois que tu as la culture
pour moi rien n'était impossible mon
groupe de rap préféré ministère amer
disait en 1994 le savoir est une âme
actuellement je suis en train de monter
une association qui s'appelle
patrimoine vert donc
patrimoine pour le côté culture pour le
côté transmission pour le côté
historique désert pour le côté street
parce que voilà on n'oublie pas d'où
l'on vient je connais
ton conclure j'aimerais vous dire que
peu importe que vous ne soyez pas bon à
l'école comme moi peu importe que vous
n'ayez pas une grande culture générale
peu importe que je n'ai aucun contact
vous pourrez quand même vont sortir si
vous avez la dalle la détermination
l'envié la passion ils sont tous des
rêves pour moi tout objectif et elle est
réalisable si on s'en donne les moyens
voilà j'en perds un peu mes mots parce
que beaucoup d'émotion j'ai pas beaucoup
mangé en plus aujourd'hui
voilà aujourd'hui j'ai décidé de
travailler pour l'inclusion et d'aider
les jeunes à leur épanouissement et à
l'aider à les aider à trouver leur voie
pour plus d'égalité des chances on peut
avoir un mauvais départ et finir par
faire des choses cool je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]